in the last video we came up with a 95
95 percent confidence interval for the
mean weight loss between the low fat
group and the control group in this
video I actually want to do a hypothesis
test to see really the test if this data
makes us believe that the low fat diet
actually does anything at all and to do
that let's set up our null and
alternative hypotheses so our null
hypothesis our null hypothesis should be
that hey this low-fat diet does nothing
and if the low-fat diet does nothing
that means that the mean the population
mean on our low-fat diet
minus the population mean on our control
should be equal to zero and this is a
completely equivalent statement this is
a completely equivalent statement to
saying that the mean the mean of the
sampling distribution of our low-fat
diet
minus the mean of the sampling
distribution of our control should be
equal to zero and that's because we've
seen this multiple times the mean of
your sampling distribution is going to
be the same thing as your population
mean so this is the same thing as that
that is the same thing as that or
another way of saying it is if we talk
if we think about the distribution if we
think about the mean of the distribution
of the difference of the sample means
and we focused on this in the last video
that that should be equal to zero
because this thing right over here this
thing right over here is the same thing
is that right over there so that is our
null hypothesis and our alternative
hypothesis is just going to be our
alternative hypothesis or I'll write it
over here our alternative hypothesis
it's just that it actually does do
something that it actually does do
something that our that our mean and
actually let's say that it actually has
an improvement so that would mean that
we have more weight loss so if we have
the mean of group one the population
mean of group one minus the population
mean of group two should be greater than
zero so this is going to be a one tailed
distribution or another way we could
view it we could view it is
that the mean of the difference of the
distributions x1 minus x2 is going to be
greater than zero these are equivalent
statements because we know that this is
the same thing as this which is the same
thing as this which is what I wrote
right over here now to do any type of
hypothesis test we have to decide on a
level of significance we have to say
what wait what what we're going to do is
we're going to assume that our null
hypothesis is correct and then given
with you know with that assumption that
the null hypothesis is correct
we're going to see whatever did what are
what is the probability of getting this
sample data right over here and if that
probability is below some threshold we
will reject the null hypothesis in favor
of the alternative hypothesis now that
probability threshold we've seen this
before is it's called the significance
level sometimes called alpha and here
we're going to decide for a significance
level a significance level of 95% or
another way to think about it we want
there to be assuming that the null
hypothesis is correct we want there to
be no more than a 5% chance of getting
this result here or no more than a 5%
chance of incorrectly rejecting the null
hypothesis when it is actually true or
that would be a type 1 error so if we
have if there's less than a 5%
probability of this happening less than
a 5% probability of this happening we're
going to reject the null hypothesis and
go less than a 5% probability given the
null hypothesis is true then we're going
to reject the null hypothesis in favor
of the alternative so let's think about
this so we have the null hypothesis let
me draw a distribution over here the
null hypothesis says that the mean of
our difference is so the mean of our of
the differences of the sampling
distributions should be equal to 0 now
in that situation what is going to be
what is going to be our critical region
here well we need a result so we need
some critical Z value here some critical
z-score or some critical I should
actually say some critical value here
because we're not this isn't
ormaline standard this isn't a normalize
standard this isn't a normalized normal
distribution but so there's some
critical value here there's some
critical value over here the hardest
thing in statistics is getting the
wording right there's some critical
value here that the probability of
getting a sample from this distribution
above that value is only 5% is only 5%
so we just need to figure out what this
critical value is and if our value is
larger than that critical value then we
can reject the null hypothesis because
that means the probability of getting
this is less than 5% we could reject the
null hypothesis and go with the
alternative hypothesis and to figure out
that critical value remember once again
we can use z-scores and we can assume
this is a normal distribution because
our sample size is large for either of
those samples we have a sample size of
100 and to figure that out we just have
to figure out the first step is to say
well what is a if we just look at a
normalized normal distribution if you
look like if you look at a normalized
normal distribution like this what is
your critical z-value critical z-value
we're getting a we're getting a result
above that z value only has a 5% chance
and to do that so this is actually
cumulative so this whole area right over
here is going to be 95% chance we can
just look at the Z table we're gonna
look it for 95% this is a one tailed
this is actually we're looking at the
one tailed case so let's look for 95%
this is the closest thing we want to err
on the side of having being a little bit
maybe to the right of this so let's say
90 5.05 is pretty good so that's one
point six five so this critical Z value
is equal to one point six five or
another way to view it is this is going
to be this distance right here is going
to be one point six five one point six
five standard deviations one point six
five standard deviations I know my
writing is really so all I'm just saying
the standard deviation of that
distribution so what is the standard
deviation of that distribution we
actually calculated in the last video
and I'll recalculate
here the standard deviation of our
distribution of the difference of the
mean the distribution of the difference
of the sample means is going to be equal
to the square root the square root of
the variance of our first population now
the variance of our first of all per
tweet we don't know it but we can
estimate it with our sample standard
deviation if you take your sample
standard deviation four point six seven
and you square it you get your sample
variance so this is the variance this is
our best estimate this is our best
estimate of the variance of the
population of the population and we get
we want to divide that by the sample
size and then plus our best estimate of
the variance of the population of Group
two which is 4.0 four squared the sample
standard deviation of Group two squared
that gives us variance divided by 100
and this gives us I did it before in the
last maybe is still sitting on my
calculator so yep is still sitting on
the calculator it's this quantity right
up here four point six seven squared
divided by 100 plus 4.04 squared divided
100 so it's point six one seven so this
right here is going to be this right
here is zero zero point six one seven so
this distance this distance right here
this distance right here is going to be
one point six five times point six one
seven so let's figure out what that is
so let's take point six one seven and we
can even add well I'll just leave it
there times one point six five so it's
one point Oh - I'll go with one point Oh
- this is this distance right here this
distance right here is one point OH - so
this what this tells us is is that there
is only a 5% chance that the difference
if we assume that these that the diet
actually does nothing if we assume that
the diet actually does nothing there is
only a 5% chance of having a difference
between these two means these two sample
the means of these two samples to have a
difference of more
then 1.02 there's only a 5% chance of
that well the mean that we actually got
is 1.91 the mean that we actually got is
one point nine one so that's sitting out
here someplace
so it definitely falls in this critical
region the probability of getting this
assuming assuming that the null
hypothesis is correct is less than five
percent so that is that is it's it's
smaller probability than our
significance level actually let me be
very clear the significance level this
alpha right here the significance level
I don't want to give you the wrong the
significance level needs to be 5% not
the 95 percent and I think I might have
said it here but I wrote down the wrong
number there I subtracted it from one by
accident probably in my head but anyway
the significance level is 5% the
probability given that the null
hypothesis is true the probability of
getting the result that we got of the
probability of getting that difference
is less than our significance level it
is less than 5% so based on the rules
that we set out for ourselves of having
a significance level of 5% we will
reject we will reject the null
hypothesis in favor of the alternative
that the diet actually does make you
lose more weight